Like a boss. Keep forgetting this show. I started the watch.
I watched the first three episodes and I absolutely fucking loved it and I
tweeted about it. It was a cartoon from Japan, I guess that called Anime,
which I did know that,
but I didn't realize it was such a divisive thing to say that you like to show
that was anime. I feel like is animated,
like the Emo of fucking cartoons.
Like I tweeted that, I liked the show called one punch man.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
all right. And the fucking responses that I got, I got, dude,
are you fucking drunk? Oh my God, you're in the enemy.
And then other people just like this, it's like to create this day. However,
I just liked the show. I've watched enough for the same type of shit.
And I was scrolling through and I was like, what the fuck is this show?
And I looked and it had five stars, four and a half, five stars,
which is why I really hope Netflix doesn't go to thumbs up, thumbs down,
like I said, because it's so fucking, you know, stubbing your toe,
thumbs down. Adolf Hitler, thumbs down. I mean,
what did the thumbs down is this is a big gap between Hitler and you know,
stop and your fucking toe. Um, anyway,
so I put this thing on and what I loved about the show,
um,
aside from the fact that I really thought it was funny that you actually kind of
got like a sense of what young people feel like in Japan as far as their view of
going into the corporate world was very similar to the empty feeling unless
you're a fucking sociopath over here.
I find like a very like common thread to that and to basically give the overall
thing the superhero in it. He's not a super, he doesn't want to be a superhero
when I'm out fighting monsters,
I never feel as if my heart's really in it anymore.
I mean I just do the hero thing as a hobby.
Alright.
And he fucking trained really hard cause he wanted to be the strongest guy in
the world. And in his training he lost all his hair,
which is hilarious and he's really self conscious about it.
But he ended up developing like this punch.
And no matter what monster he runs into,
he doesn't give a shit whether they kill him.
He's just completely devoid of any like passion or emotion.
Like what happens to you when you get shoved into a fucking cubicle.
[inaudible]
and uh,
and he's got this one punch and he just fucking can punch so hard that no matter
how fucking bad ass the monster is, he gives them one,
somebody said they should have called the show, the right they have Fred.
He gives them the fucking fire in the fucking,
in the face is Eddie Murphy says in the face,
the
um, and their fucking head explodes and the monsters that he fights,
you also get more of an insight into where people's heads are at,
uh, in Japan. And it was like, you know, one of the monsters you fought with,
some giant virus sent here by the Earth to get rid of all the humans because of
what we'd done to the planet. So there's environmental thing.
Then my favorite one was this guy who was crab man. He was half, like up top.
And he was all a crab and then the bottom he was,
he was half a guy and he was in put the bottom half.
He's in his bare feet and tidy. Whities Ben,
you're a new businessman already hating the daily grind.
I ate too much crap and turned into this crab Alon Day.
You should be crapping in your pants right now.
Why aren't you running [inaudible]?
And the guy's like, oh, I ate so much crab meat that I became a fucking crab.
And to me he represented the upper 1% corporate guys, you know,
on some power lunch. Just eaten all the fucking Sushi, just take, take, take,
take, take, nothing spiritual about them. So he gave him me all right there,
Fred
[inaudible].
And then he fought this fucking Lei and she had command of all the mosquitoes
and she'd sit the mosquitoes on everybody suck all the blood out of you and all
your fucking energy. And then it would make her stronger.
And to me it's like all this is a gold dig in blood sucking whore.
All right, come on.
That wasn't nearly enough love to satisfy my niece.
Now go get some more for me.
And then once she got it to do it to all the animals and everybody there,
she didn't need them mosquitoes anymore.
She told all the mosquitoes to go fuck themselves. And I'm like,
slash this is also somebody who becomes successful and forgets where they come
from. And they look at everybody where they used to be.
It's like a bunch of fucking p ons,
a bunch of little insignificant little mosquitoes.
Hi, I no longer need my tiny little helpers. I mean,
look at how strong guy be calm,
right? It's a lot of levels to it or you.
He just get fucking high and watch this baldheaded dude fucking punch half a
crab in the head. He wants you to explode. I enjoyed it.
Oh, oh, oh. [inaudible] keep it up.
Let me see the uh, oh, the Manet comes in,
parade, comes to town, going down. Broadway is a one way street.
When would you have a way I go.